finden wir 100 Dinge die ich mit meinem
Eimer pistaziencreme machen kann wir
sind angekommen bei part 4 ganz viele
haben sich einen Pistazien Eiskaffee
gewünscht zur leckeren pistaziencreme
habe ich kalte Milch gegeben das ganze
dann gut miteinander vermischt und ein
wenig aufgeschäumt dazu kam dann die
Eiswürfel die haben das alles noch mal
schön eiskalt gemacht der frische heiße
Espresso darf dann rein der kühlt sofort
ab das ganze mit frischer Sahne serviert
und natürlich noch mal pistaziencreme on
top gegeben ich muss sagen ich war an
diesem Tag total schlecht gelaunt und
dachte mir ich mache die Challenge
weiter und dieser Pistazien als Kaffee
hat mich echt wieder glücklich gemacht